hey hello everyone my name is Zakir kale
I'm a machine learning engineer and
developer advocate at Google and I also
AM the co-organizer of the central
London data science Meetup
how many of you have attended one of my
meet ups Oh quite a few
oh there's a couple cool so yeah so Oh
No
so can you all hear me from here is this
on ok cool so yeah a bit a bit more
about me my sort of things I'd like to
do is is build machine learning into
applications I was previously a software
engineer and then I started learning
machine learning on like Coursera and I
always was interested in how could you
actually get machine learning working in
in applications the applications that I
wanted them to get working in weren't
necessarily business critical
applications the first one was this so
this is a physical neural network so
taking a slight kit learned model and
training a neural network in that and
then showing the weights on like RG B's
so you can see like incredibly useful
well like when I first saw it it was the
first time I ever saw learning happening
so it was kind of cool to see if I can
show at the top there's there's a little
at the very start there's like a bright
activation over here and it kind of
moves it kind of slides over to the
right-hand side again like I can't learn
anything from it but it kind of looks
cool the next application or one of the
more recent ones was this here's a this
really like set the tone for the kind of
talk this might be if the Wi-Fi works
okay the Wi-Fi is as unreliable as
predicted as Michael mentioned okay cool
so let's imagine nothing happens the
other thing I built was this bike that
was for the PI data conference that
happened two months ago one month ago
happen in the past and what it did is it
did object detection facing behind the
bicycle and then if there was say a
dangerous object it would light up the
handlebars on the side of the handlebars
where the danger existed so you can see
here this is the I put in the video the
videos flipped so the bus is on the left
the car is on the right so the bus is
green and the car is red and it's the
size of the handlebars that it lights up
on is representative of how close in the
direction of the thing so that one's
like kind of useful and if you're
interested in that project you should
follow me on Twitter because I may or
may not be working with a certain bike
company to actually build this into a
real bike so you know stay tuned for
that okay enough about me what about you
so how many people in the room are data
scientists that's a lot of data
scientist how many people have done any
kind of machine learning ok how many
people know what linear regression is ok
so so if you don't know what linear
regression is
I have I like to I like to assume no
knowledge I like that's my style it's my
style I'll skip over this slide but just
in case you've forgotten what linear
regression is I'd like to show off this
really cool tool which linear regression
to variables you changed it to oh I know
yeah change the two variables and it
changes the line so okay now everyone
knows what linear regression is I want
to highlight not just knowing what it is
knowing that we could use a line to
predict something I want to draw
attention to the fact that not only can
we predict the the tabs are bothering me
let me just Rhea okay not only can you
use a line to predict but after you've
learnt your line you can maybe get some
sort of insight from the coefficients
that it's found so in this case I'm
imagining I'm a farmer trying to predict
the way to pineapples based on their age
again very relatable and the idea is
that although yeah we can make
predictions using this line but just by
looking at the coefficient that it's
found we can kind of see that okay the
the weight goes up slightly slower than
the age and then when the age is zero
the pineapple weighs five whatever it
weighs kilograms magic pineapples but
the idea is I want to sort of talk as it
like him it might come back later in the
talk who knows but we might talk about
how we can use the coefficients that
have learned for insight rather than
just using a line to make predictions
okay so basketball again smooth
transitions I I play a bit of sport and
I wanted to get out more so someone
suggested oh maybe you should try
basketball because there's a lot of
basketball courts in London and I went
away I bought a boss bought a basketball
I went to the court I tried to shoot
anybody play basketball by the way come
people yeah I tried to try to shoot some
hoops as they say and it was very hard
it's surprisingly difficult even when
you've got no opposition so the idea is
I was kidding I was getting bored quite
quickly and I wanted to do something
what I usually do is I'll do something
I'll get bored with it and then I'll try
to put some like sort of tack on it does
anybody else do this well they started
thinking about apps that you could do to
do with the thing that you're bored with
yeah it's kind of coming so that's the
idea so if I can't be good at it kind of
a cool doing it this is the idea so
rather than build an app maybe do
something artsy so who's ever heard of
long exposure photography who's done it
does anybody done it yeah so it's it's
the idea that if you have done or yeah
if you have it I see a year that you can
take a camera usually quite an expensive
camera and rather than a camera just
opening and closing the lens to take a
photo you can open the open the lens
and/or open the shutter leave it open
and then any kind of light that happens
in the in the image gets kept and so you
get these kind of long trails of
whatever you do
so there's oh if I could do this with
the basketball shot I might be able to
get a really cool light even if it
misses in fact if it misses it becomes a
more interesting trail of light so it's
a win-win so that was the idea so the I
took the reflective tape that you get on
cones you can buy it on eBay for like a
pound and wrapped it wrong the scene of
the basketball and I didn't have one of
these cameras that could do the long
exposure shot all I had was my phone and
what was kind of important for the
application using this reflective tape
is that I needed a light source close to
the camera for the reflection to come
back and shine very bright and
fortunately like most phones have a
torch built-in right next to the web
right next to the camera so it was
perfect just set it up set it on video
mode and then make sure the torch is on
and you get the ball kind of lightened
up nice and brightly in the night and so
the idea is I went out when it was a bit
dark and shots and hoops you can see I'm
quite good I got five in a row already
the idea is I would take this footage
and I would pass it through some Python
code and work like the trails because I
guess the delight from the ball is a
very distinct color in the in the frame
and so yeah I went through it I actually
used the Python package that I used was
psychic video so if you ever working is
anybody you psyche it video before no
one well you should
psychic video allows you to put in like
an mp4 file or or I don't know who works
with avi but put in a video file and it
will take a video file and turn it into
a big long numpy alright so it's very
memory intensive here's the link I've
got these links littered throughout the
entire talk so if you're interested in
the code used to produce this you can
like snapshot of that I'll have all the
links available at the end so yeah this
is this is the shot so here's these
still of it it doesn't look quite as
cool as I initially planned like I
didn't have the long glowing stream
mainly because like the frame rate of
the video and the code I wrote was
pretty like naive of just finding a
distinct color and not putting in much
of a threshold above or below and you
can see even like there's lights in the
background because of the street lights
so it wasn't what I wanted but then I
thought looking at it it kind of looks
like data yeah so could I do something
data related so I thought to myself if I
can't look good in it or if I'm not good
at it and don't look cool doing it the
obvious next step does anybody know what
it is that's right do some machine
learning so the idea is I take this data
and crop it out crap either very
interesting bit that looks like a kind
of curve or a line put it in put it in
some Jupiter notebooks and then I try to
do my linear regression oh it didn't
work so yeah so standard linear
regression model won't work for this I
don't know if anyone was gonna guess
that but that didn't work but is there
another line that does fit this like do
I know how to describe the line that I
just shot and the answer is yes
Wikipedia to the rescue a trajectory
equation should fit my data and the idea
is this this equation that everybody
knows I've got a
or animation or the thing before so yeah
same exact principle it's just a line
with when it loads there is it's just a
line with two two variables so an angle
of the shot and the velocity of the shot
so it's almost identical to linear
regression and now the question is is
this the same as linear regression hands
up with says this is the same as linear
regression all right okay hands up if
this is called linear regression if I
try to fit this line hands up if it's
called linear regression hands up if
it's definitely not called linear
regression okay I also don't know and I
also I asked some people around the
office this morning data scientists in
office they're also confused so if I set
the access to be the variables oh I
don't know how that works anyway we'll
chat off shorts but yeah genuinely I
don't know is it still technically
regression it's definitely regression
still I don't know but yeah that's
something to think about very thoroughly
as I'm talking for the rest of the talk
so the idea is yeah we got this equation
and how can I do it well I've got a
notebook here and the idea is I can code
this equation fortunately there's like
they don't have to fit trajectory curve
and scikit-learn and they're not even in
Kerris either so I have to code up cut
it up myself and for that I have a
little notebook here
maybe we'll chat afterwards okay can
everyone see that code yep I'm at the
back cool
so what I'm doing here is I'm
downloading the image of my data I'm
displaying it actually I'll make sure I
don't spoil the surprise by clearing all
the outputs cool
so I'll display I'll display my data so
here's the crop type data of my other
shot that I just made I'm going to defy
the tantrum also in here I define okay
what are the two variables that I'm
going to be tweaking and changing to fit
my data again in that little animation I
showed I was tweaking and changing the
angle in the force
so I'll declare those then I'll go down
here's the description of them all so
here's the equation at the top and all
I'm doing here is I'm actually just
writing it out in tensorflow
syntax so you can actually see like the
first the first part of this the tan x x
that's just this first line X x TF tan
and then this equation is actually
working in radians so I've got a little
function here that converts radians to
degrees and yeah it's just right that
equation in the tensor flow code I will
run that okay and then I will just show
it so here is my data along side the
default version of my unlike tensor flow
code okay so the red line is the the
model where it is which it's quite far
off the data so what I can do that is
like super cool is I can go in here and
say okay force variable there we go
first variable dot a sign there it is
super fast and we're gonna give it I
think it started at 50 let's give it two
hundred and we'll run the same so Oh
getting closer
alright let's do the same for the angle
variable here we go
assign that to what was it sorry that
like 48 let's give it a oh - hi I didn't
know that was gonna happen
let's do 50
okay ah this is so hard to try to fit
the variables to think if only there is
a way so we have a machine learning we
have optimizers I don't know if data
scientists are aware of optimization but
yeah we can run an optimizer to do the
exact thing that I was going to be
manually we'll run it for say 200 or 100
epochs we'll be generous and it will go
through constantly tweaking and changing
the variable variable and we'll finally
display our final model
oh let's let's fit it some more it needs
some more time okay what both we got now
close enough okay so it's wet through
it's tweaked and changed the variable
until it's fit the curve to our to my
shot now just I'll just look at the look
at the variable so if I go to my angle
shots angle variable num pee num pulley
and then P there we go
63 degrees is the angle of my shot the
force behind my shot is 123 does anybody
know what 123 me maybe we'll take a
guess hey I mean logically it should be
like a reasonable metric of force
however I haven't scaled the image when
I put it in its just measuring the
pixels so so what's very very nice as it
tells me how many pixels of force I'm
throwing the ball so if this was like if
this image was to scale and I did throw
the ball say a kilometer this would be
123 meters per second but because I
didn't scale the image it's 123 pixels
per second which is useful but we'll
just ignore I mainly focused on the
angle and why am I mainly focused on the
angle good question here's an animation
of the fitting that just happened I
usually when I when I show this badge I
usually showing this to people who
haven't done machine learning or worked
with Python or matplotlib and they don't
appreciate how hard it is to make an
animated graph and so if you do
appreciate how hard it is to make an
Emma graph you can see all the code to
do the animated graph alongside fitting
a model while showing the model fitting
to the graph so there's the link to all
that that's all in like a that is the
first time anyone's ever clapped for
this but it's what I love it I love it
okay cool thank you this is a question I
get asked a lot so I've done all this
I've worked out the angle of my shot but
it's I don't know what to do with it
so what I'm gonna do is what I normally
do when I've done something called in
somebody asked this question is I a
retro actively make up a use case so the
idea is I went away and I asked my
friend who is a basketball semi-pro and
I said okay if I want to shoot a ball
from from this distance on the court
like close up and I want to move to
further away in the court how do i do
what do I change about my technique and
doing that and she said you don't need
to change your technique you techne
should stay the exact same the only
thing has to change is the force behind
the ball so I'm getting nods yeah okay
the force behind the ball should change
so power comes from your legs or any
anywhere but the angle of the ball
should stay constant and I thought
excellent so that gives me a reason of
why I've done all this so if I can work
out the angle of all of my shots and
work on how consistent I am in theory
this application that I that I'm
developing can be used to measure how
good of a basketball player you are if
you're consistent in theory you're good
yes okay so what have I done if I want
to analyze a shot it's only six easy
steps so first of all to record the
shots then to cycle home because I have
to do it all on my computer trim the
video to the exact point where I take my
shots apply pre-processing so in the
first case I used elect the reflective
tape on the ball turns out that was
completely a waste of time there's
actually a pre-processing technique that
I've done previously and I didn't think
of
where I take one frame and subtract it
from the next frame and then only the
pixels that have changed remain and I
apply that across multiple frames and
you get like a trail so you don't need
to wrap tape around the ball does
anybody know what this pre-processing
technique is called
okay I don't either
but what I call it is Delta frames so if
you do know the actual word for a please
tell me afterwards because I've been
telling everyone that it's called Delta
frames so trim the video apply these
Delta frames go through crop the shot in
because my model where I fit a curve it
assumes that the start of the shot
starts at the origin so zero zero so I'd
make sure I crop my shot in then run my
model that fits the line to the curve it
runs and then at the very end I get the
angle of a shot so pretty
straightforward the only thing is a
cycling home takes about 10 minutes
stripping the video I have to do that
manually in Python which takes about
five minutes to find find the point in
the video the pre-processing is super
cheap that's just a bit of Python code
minus 1 matrix from the next matrix
cropping this shot takes about five
minutes manually adjusting the
parameters and stuff writing the model
it's about a second to actually fit the
model if it's if it starts at reasonable
defaults so the idea is I want to play
more basketball I don't wanna have to
cycle home the idea the idea is what can
I do to solve this problem well what I
usually do to solve problems is you
throw a neural networks at them so I'm
gonna throw a neural network there and
then I'm gonna throw a neural network at
the crumbing of the shot so then that
will automate all the manual steps and
then I can not have to go home and play
my basketball so that's I'm gonna do now
I go through first thing I do is need to
request access
all right what you would have seen here
is just a video of that ghostly image of
me shooting a ball but is what happens
when you share slides across corporate
accounts so yeah you would have seen a
video of me going taking shots and you
see just just the white outline of me
taking the shot and this is where I
would have explained that rather than
first of all trimming the video to my
shot and then running the pre-processing
because the the pre-processing that the
Delta image stuff is so cheap to do it's
just subtracting a matrix from another
matrix I should just do that for all the
videos and it's really unfortunate you
can't see the video because the idea is
I always showed you as I'm taking the
shot I could just train a image
classifier to say okay whenever you see
a nice clear arc in my shot predict that
it's I'm taking a shot and then if I'm
running around or it's all fuzzy and
noisy then just say I'm not making a
shot so it's like a shot or not
predictor so if you see a nice clean arc
in the in the video it's a shot if you
don't it's not a shot so how would I do
this I would go through and I would
create shots models so yeah this is if
you see this if you see this it's gonna
be a nice clean shot let's just say yes
to a shot if you see anything else
it's not a shot binary classification
here's done binary classification yes
everyone all right the next bit so the
data so this is the I usually don't go
into the detail about to go into because
to collect data for this I just recorded
myself taking a shot and I didn't want
to I knew I had to label the data so
that created this kind of negative
feedback that I didn't want to collect a
lot of data so I recorded one session of
me taking shot approximately five
minutes of video and so I wanted I
needed to augment the data I needed to
you know kind of get more data from the
data I collected and so I've got a
notebook here that shows how I just took
each image translated it like five
pixels - laughs five pixels up and down
who hears never heard of like data
augmentation with images yeah it's like
quite like a common thing to do I didn't
need to do that because it turns like
Karis actually has that built in now so
good thing good thing to note is if
you're ever doing an image image
classification in chaos there's actually
just a generator here
and you can say here's my data I'm gonna
feed it into my model it's gonna
automatically augment your model by
twisting it and doing even more stuff
like color changes and brightness
changes so that was a bit of a time
wasted when I did that the next portion
is how after I've built my model okay
what is the code I used for my model so
I used Karis to train the model the
actual model structure I borrowed from
the Eminence example so here's heard of
the eminence handwritten digits it's
like the hello world of image
recognition so Kerris has a really good
example on their github of model
structure that trains for the Eminence
really well Eminence is detecting curves
and lines so I figured mines kind of a
curvy line so find an application that
does something similar and look at what
they did for inspiration the only main
thing to note is in their version of
mole they're doing a multi
classification I just care about if it's
yes or no so I just got to make sure
that it's a the output is a 1 node and a
single sigmoid activation so that's
gonna give me a binary classifier on to
how do I actually bring this model to
the basketball court
here's productionize the machinery model
a lot fewer people and people who say
they do the machine learning so that's
yeah it's a it's a tricky thing
production izing machinery new models
the sort of the most fun tool I found
being enough previously a web developer
I started using tensorflow js here's
heard of tensor ojs a couple of people
okay so tensorflow j s is a tensor flow
library that runs in JavaScript as the
name suggests what's really cool about
it is it actually has a slightly it's
it's nice it's got a slightly different
API than a normal tensor the tennis pro
api it's actually got a quite a few
better high-level api so it's got things
like a little line of code that will
take an image and feed it directly into
your machine or an algorithm like it'll
do the transformations for you and it
also has an API that just takes care of
models and converts them into tensorflow
j/s models and allows you to just run
them in the browser so it's incredibly
useful for this application it's perfect
because I've got some tensor
or I've got some carrots models and here
is the first one so we've got my shot or
not application I've built the Charis
model and I've got the I put here being
shown all in real time so this is all
actually running in my browser and you
can see as I shoot I'm doing the
calculation of the delta image all in
the browser as well and you see it
spikes up when I shoot so that's it
there's also a little button down here
that says camera and what's nice by this
is I don't have anyone ever try to use
build camera applications so this is
this is very overfit to basketball
courts but the closest thing we have
where is so we have the closest thing to
a basketball which is a loaf of bread so
I don't I need to it's a very over fit
model it it's so over fit it only knows
what I'm shooting from this side of the
screen so you can see where it needs
improving so I'm going to attempt to oh
it's such a good model I'm going to
attempt it needs it needs to also think
that I'm running around I didn't I
didn't train it on blank images like
here we go I'm gonna throw it up there
you'll imagine where the basket is ok
there we go that's fine thank you very
alright there's the shot or not model
available available on my github what's
actually catechol for that because it's
all tensorflow jazz it's all run in
JavaScript my production ization
platform is just the tenth or github
pages so if you go to the github repo
there's a link and it's all running from
github pages so yeah you can
productionize machine learning in github
let's move on so we've got I've got I
know when I'm taking a shot or not the
idea is now I want to crop in where I'm
taking my shot from I could do an image
to image model that's a bit that's a bit
crazy to do that I could simplify it by
saying okay if I just know where to crop
it from that's useful and I can do the
rest of the cropping in code so I could
just imagine yeah X and y axis
just tell me where thy shot is taken
from so I need to predict two numbers
the x coordinate and the y coordinate of
the base of the shot and I can just
encode say okay crop from this position
and the audio the auto the auto cropping
model then is not a classification well
it's actually just a regression model
and yeah where'd a shot prick me two
numbers though not just a single number
yeah two for x and y and yep this is the
way it's gonna be applied I didn't
actually know this when I built it it is
apparently called multi target
regression so yeah good thing to know
moving on where to crop it from this is
the date I did also do this sort of
time-wasting thing of writing my own
code to augment the data set left right
up down although in this case it wasn't
entirely wasted because if I were to do
it through the Charis API the key I need
to also augment the Y output in this
case so if I translate my image to the
left five pixels I need to also
translate the why I put to the left
which I don't believe the Charis API
supports if anybody knows any kind of
data augmentation tools that do do this
please tell me afterwards because this
was very hard to do the actual shot the
exact same as before because it's
predicting with the same input data I
don't see why I needed to change the
model at all the only thing I needed to
change the model was the output so
because I'm predicting two numbers it's
going to be two notes and a linear
activation that's going to give me two
regression outputs and moving swiftly on
the demo that demos this is similar sort
of thing very clean UI as you can see
I'm just going to wait for this to load
there we go
nope waiting for the video to load now
there we go
so we've got the video loading I've got
the output of my shot or not running at
the bottom and I also have the output of
my wear from model or the where's the
base of the shot happening you can see
it kind of just like doesn't know what
to do when I'm not shooting obviously
because it wasn't trained on data of
when I was not shooting it was only
trained on data when I was actually
making a shot so it only knows what to
do when it sees that nice clean arc and
you can see it kind of gets a bit
confused and then what as soon as I make
a shot it kind of jumps into action I
didn't add the news camera function to
this just to save myself a bit of
embarrassment but that is both those
modal's running in real time in the
browser as well and you can see I've got
the frame right here so it's but 50 60
fps what's pretty cool about tents
projets is that it's using OpenGL under
the hood so whatever device you're using
it's gonna try to use any kind of
graphical acceleration that the device
has to run these inferences a lot faster
so there's those two models running the
final thing is that I bring it all
together so I've got the trimming of the
video happening as a Karass model that I
built and productionize intensive ljs
the cropping of the shot again built in
Karis productionize intensive ljs and
the code I wrote at the start that
actually fit that linear model because
at the because the tentacle JS library
has a kind of carbon copy of the
original tensorflow library
I just reproduced that codes that say
describe a trajectory equation I just
reproduce that in JavaScript in the
tensorflow JavaScript syntax and that
runs the exact same way so the idea is
that I will use our feed in image it
will say okay am I making a shot if I am
okay where am I making a shot from okay
cool crop that and run my linear model
to fit to fit this line and then I just
pluck out the two variables that it's
optimized so the angle and the force and
it all runs inside a web page and here
is the final demo of layer loads in a
reasonable hour
here we go
here we go all right so I've got I know
exciting I've got the video at the top
running you'll see a little flash of a
cross that's the where model running and
you see down here work pretty is the
data so it's the cropping of the data at
the bottom and then I click this little
checkbox and it's going to run the model
as well to fit boom there we go so the
angle of that shot there was 52 degrees
let's see how consistent I am
professionals are within one degree of
each shot 57 so I'm not a professional
and now I know that that is that is that
is he that is the entire demo 53 again
yeah not good that's Italian but thank
you all so much for listening
here's between I'm aware
a lot of questions yeah me too
for Zach there's a microphone on sit in
front of you
oh yeah hello yeah love Amy I'm spying
out go ah it's polynomial yes whoo
that's a load off my chest
okay polynomial regression did it help
you get any better at basketball
ah so interestingly enough after I
finished building this I was already
bought a basketball I'm moving on to new
grounds
I I really appreciate you create this so
when you use it to try to help yourself
improving the technique of shooting the
basketball so I took a question so the
idea is that this app that that I I mean
I came up with the use case halfway
through building it the idea was that so
long as it can measure how consistent I
am it's it's less of helping me improve
and we're just keeping track of how well
I'm improving because the idea is that
if you're consistent in shooting then
you're a better basketball player so
yeah it's less about improving your shot
and more just tracking your progress
yeah yeah so I have oh yes so the
question was I was capturing the the
shot in in just a 2d flat image and is
there an option to potentially if the
camera was it positioned differently to
capture a shot from three-dimensional
space or like considering the
three-dimensional space of the shot so
the idea is that if if you're able to
because as soon as you change the angle
I did like I was very careful to stay
like perfectly flat to it to make my
life as easy as possible as soon as you
move like in a different angle the
trajectory equation won't fit anymore it
because it the direct to the the
trajectory equation only applies to like
a two-dimensional trajectory
I'm sure there's definitely a trajectory
equation for three-dimensional
trajectory that's then sort of I don't
know what you call it like projected
onto a two-dimensional plane so long as
you encode that in the tensor flow model
it should be able to fit fit it so
whatever whatever a special new angle
that you start shooting the ball at as
long as you find an equation that
describes the the new curve you should
be able
just encode it in tensorflow I want it
should just work it should do yeah yeah
yeah it's definitely it's definitely one
of the many downsides of this
application oh yeah at the bank
have you tried to use just regular
scikit-learn for the trajectory curve
fitting tensor flow so I I didn't I
didn't use tense for because it's fun
what do you say Kim in fact for I
couldn't find I didn't know cuz the idea
was I wanted to find the angle of my
shot and I could fit just like a I don't
know like a neural network model or more
and more advanced polynomial model I
don't know how to make custom
polynomials in in scikit-learn so that
was the reason why actually do I I don't
know I didn't think about it long enough
so now I chose tensor flow because I
thought that was the right solution but
now that I'm thinking about it maybe I
didn't have to you sense for though that
require a lot of training data I feel
and I would have to label the training
data well I I've considered that like
maybe cutting out some of the steps and
getting let me just have one neuron our
mole that tells me the angle actually I
could use this current model to take
some data and produce those labels and
then train that into another neural
network model so that would be a good
next step
yeah I could use this for the labeling
connection yeah it's a good idea yeah
with the back
hello yeah right see yeah I just had
this thought where if you're really
closer than then your angle does have to
change
yeah yeah yeah did you manage to find
like a distance where that kind of
worked so the question was uh when you
get close to the to the net then you do
need to change your angle it doesn't
apply anymore I didn't consider all the
edge cases for this the idea was a
Freeth free-throw shooting that's like
one of the main metrics of basketball
like how good you are how good you are
from the free-throw line
and in that sort of area so yes I didn't
consider the edge cases of the layups I
believe they're called so in theory it
could because it's just running on the
web browser and you can add in any kind
of gamification you want I'm trying to
think I can't sew it like every time I
tell people just in person that I'll
build this basketball app and they say
Oh does it tell you when you make a shot
I'm like no without have been much
better okay
it can tell you the exact angle of your
shot though I can't think of a other
game that does that I was thinking
because there's a database online that
tells you the exact angle of every
professional basketball there's a church
shots
I see I was thinking maybe you can you
can play and I can tell you not the
angle that you shoot at but who do you
shoot like so it's like yeah which could
be cool or you have to I don't know I
honestly don't know it was a very very
not thought through application yeah
can you hear okay so how I have a
question with respect to your negative
something
particle sampling the way how you sample
negatives instance a sampling yeah okay
the the one with with hoops and the one
with our hoops so if you sample like
order without hoops like close to sixty
two degree would that be more difficult
to train the models so the question was
I sampled the hoop they shot or not the
the hoops are not hopes you say in the
city no no I mean in the degree you like
close to sixty six sixty six close to
six series oh yeah so there is a there
yeah there's an eighties very over fit I
will admit that for example you can see
cutis you can see also it shows
especially shows in the where I'm
shooting from mobile because when it's
when I'm not doing anything it's it's
drifting towards the right-hand side of
the screen with the shot or not I try to
augment the data as much as possible and
most of my shots were between sixty and
seventy degrees so I'm always I haven't
tested it with with data out so those
ranges so it is almost definitely
overfit to where I'm shooting from and
more to that also the model that I
trained at the end I set the default
values of the line that gets fit too
close to 60 and 70 and yeah I cheated a
lot in getting this to work yep
I don't know their age data around
basketballers heights and the angles
that they shoot at and there is there is
apparently an optimal like there's a
there's a theoretical optimal angle of a
shot to make the basketball appear as
wide as possible and yeah there's a lot
of stuff around that so there's probably
an answer to that question but I don't
have it
oh oh that was that's good so the idea
is a this is if you already know the
height of the person what is the
optimizer they should be shooting at
that's that is probably true
and I guess the the idea is this
application will tell you what you're
currently shooting at and you can use
both of those metrics to try to fit it
together so yeah that's a good like
attachment to the app be like oh you
should be shooting at this angle shoot
at a higher angle actually that would
help improve so that would yeah that
would actually make the application
useful no but so that's that's actually
no that's I should definitely add that
because that would actually make it you
could see the how much you should change
your angle by so yeah that's a good
thing
thank you
[Applause]